joining us now Lucy Fraser hi it's good
to see you thanks for joining us on the
program I don't know if you just heard
Dave Whelan from as the aslift the train
drivers Union uh saying they are
prepared to strike for 20 years if
necessary until this government or
future government comes to the table and
gives them what they want
well I think it's really disappointing
because I think the government
um is helping facilitate uh discussions
uh we are of course in a cost of living
crisis where we need to keep inflation
down that means we need to control
public spending and train drivers get on
average around 60 000 pounds and I do
think it's important that they come to
the table so that they don't disrupt the
journeys of thousands millions of people
across the country of course it's
slightly different with public spending
and train drivers isn't it but
um do you think that train drivers are
paid enough money at the moment is that
what you're saying well as I'm saying
you know it's important that they come
to the table to
discuss uh the right solution they say
they are they say it's the fact that the
transport secretary has not even
bothered to talk to them for six months
uh well I know that the transport
secretary and the rail Minister have had
a number of conversations and of course
they facilitate those discussions as you
say but train driver because on average
are paid around sixty thousand pounds
and is that enough
well that's a matter of for the unions
and those employing the train drivers
but of course I I suspect many people
around the country would think that
sixty thousand pounds was quite a lot of
money sounds as though you do as well
well I'm not involved obviously in those
uh discussions I'm the culture secretary
but I know that the Secretary of State
for transport and the rail Minister have
had a number of discussions and are very
keen to make sure that people across the
country can go around their belief it's
chilly though isn't it to think that we
could have disruption for 20 years on
the railway well what we've seen
postcovid is of course that people
aren't necessarily returning to Journeys
on the train and the government has
subsidized quite a lot of trade journals
and I think it's really important that
we make sure that we get those trains
back up and running
um talk to me about the competition and
markets Authority who will be reporting
a little bit later on
um the thought is that it's likely to
prove that we're being ripped off by
supermarkets when it comes to buying
petrol well that's why the uh Chancellor
recently called in all The Regulators to
discuss whether they were passing on
um the cost of living issues to their
customers because it is a concern not
just in relation to petrol but across
the board we want to make sure that when
prices do come down that those are
passed on to customers and the
chancellor had a meeting with a number
of regulators over the course of the
last week so what's your message to
supermarkets this morning
it is really important that they pass on
those reductions to customers because I
know people are feeling the squeeze at
the moment with the cost of living and
it's important that when prices come
down consumers feel that as well and
what's your message to Consumers who
feel that they are being ripped off by
these supermarkets that are basically
profiteering they would use a different
word but let's call it what it is
well of course we have seen um High food
inflation and that's across the globe so
we've seen it here but we've seen it in
other countries in Europe and indeed
more widely than that but it is really
important as you say that those prices
are fun to do that well as I said the
chancellor called in a number of
regulators last week because it's for
The Regulators to look at this he called
them in and he made his position very
clear and I hope that The Regulators
will be having those conversations uh
with the supermarkets as well and the
government basically saying yes we would
like you to bring those prices down and
if you don't they were going to look at
ways of forcing you to do that well you
will remember as well when petrol was
when the reductions in petrol
came in uh and and should have been
passed on to Consumers earlier last year
you'll remember the chancellor then uh
also wrote to all uh those companies who
were should have brought those prices
down so of course government keeps an
eye on this we want to ensure that we
look after uh customers and we are
taking action as a government as well so
obviously supporting people with the
cost of living are paying um at least
half the typical Bill three and a half
thousand pounds to keep those Energy
prices low okay you've got a plan to
tackle anti-social Behavior over the
summer tell me about it so what we're
announcing today is three million pounds
to go to uh provide activities for young
people over the summer like well well
that could be education art drama what
we know is that young people if they
don't have things to do they go down the
wrong path not the right one so we're
giving them something to do and
something somewhere to go so we're
announcing three million pounds over the
course of the summer to enable people to
have a constructive summer not a not a
one that's going to affect other
people's lives in terms of antisocial
Behavior who do you think is most
responsible for tackling teenagers
anti-social Behavior I mean we've seen
what's been happening in France over the
last week president macron appealing to
mothers and fathers to sort our
anti-social Behavior what role should a
government have in that
I think government plays a role parents
play a role communities play a role I
think it's holistic and we are doing a
number of things to make sure that as I
said we give children something to do
and somewhere to go so in my department
we're responsible for sport and for
youth clubs and we've seen significant
investment in those even since I was
appointed in the last four months so in
the last four months we've refurbished a
thousand uh We've announced that we've
refurbished a thousand tennis courts
over the course of the last year we're
building multi-sport pitchers across the
country 1600 we announced just recently
and we're putting investment into into
youth clubs as well on Friday we
announced investment in swimming pools
so government plays a role in order to
provide facilities for people and we're
absolutely taking up that baton but
communities parents schools everyone
plays a role what would the British
government do to try to resolve uh six
nights of rioting by teenagers we've
seen in France how would you start to
tackle something like that in this
country oh well of course that's a
matter for the French no it's not
because I said if it's in this country
well in this country we are doing a
number of things to tackle uh violent
crime in fact crime has gone down
overall by these 50 percent included in
this country because specifically about
teenagers rioting setting things on fire
burning a vehicle and driving it towards
a mayor's family's home where his wife
breaks her leg getting the kids out of
the house I mean the French are
obviously not doing enough how would you
start to tackle something like that well
we have taken uh quite a lot of action
to reduce violent crime in this country
including putting sentences I'm talking
about rioting specifically teenagers out
of control how would you deal with it
well in this country I'm pleased we're
not seeing those things on the streets
why do you think matters well what we
have done over I I've mentioned some of
the action that we've taken in relation
to ensuring that there's positive things
for young people to do but in addition
to that we are we've also put
significant amount of funds into but it
starts with the race in this country
there are issues with police and race in
this country and yet we don't see
teenagers trying to burn places down
why do you think that is well if if you
just let me answer the question I've
asked you several times you just haven't
answered we've put in significant funds
in order to
um stop young people going down the
wrong path so I could point to a number
of measures that we put in place uh one
in the in the youth Justice space so the
ministry of justice has a three million
300 million pound uh fund over the next
three years to help support young people
who are at risk of going down this path
the home office has the youth endowment
fund 200 million pounds which
particularly targets uh young people in
relation to
um serious violence exploitation uh
young children and girls going down the
wrong path so that's what we are doing
well what we are doing is that we're not
going to comment on the French why not
uh what I'm going to say is what we are
doing 20 miles away what we are doing in
this country is we have targeted action
in order to support young people who
might be going down the wrong path and
that's why we are announcing today the
three million pounds to help people who
who are on the who might otherwise
I've allowed you to tell me about that
you're not worried at all about what's
happening in France of course I'm
worried about what's happening in France
uh of course I'm married uh for the
French and for French people and of
course it's not helpful when there is
unrest in countries uh across the globe
that sometimes feeds through into this
country but what I'm saying is that we
understand we need to give people a
positive uh give people positive
activities here we need to support young
people and we need to help them not go
down that path which is why we're
continuing to announce funds to support
young people okay I'm almost out of time
but I just wanted to ask you quickly
tomorrow's just reminded me
um one of the ideas from this group of
conservative MPS who are launching their
own immigration plan today they one of
the ideas is to stop visas for care
workers really
well what they are saying is that we
need to control immigration and you will
know uh the significant steps the
government is taking to control both
illegal immigration and on that and
illegal immigration stopping visas for
care workers well what uh what we need
to do is upskill people in this country
to make sure that we do have sufficient
workers
um who to to to provide services that we
need and you will know on Friday we
announced the NHS Workforce plan which
is going to significantly invest in our
Workforce here both in order to retain
staff and to recruit them as well as
employing of course
technical measures and taking advantage
of technology to in order to ensure that
we look after people across the country
in terms like you support them we must
leave it there thanks very much indeed
for joining us thank